hey everybody
welcome to live coding with Jessie I'm
Jessie and today we're gonna do
something weird we're gonna code in PHP
nothing wrong with PHP it's just weird
because we usually don't code with the
HV we roll with JavaScript around here
but I have to I don't really have
another option so let me kind of break
down what the problem is and how I think
we're gonna solve it and if any of you
have better ideas please let me know I'm
open to trying anything at this point
because I need to get some data it's
really important and our current setup
won't allow forgetting the data that
that we need so here's here's what's
happening I've made these custom fields
so if you're not familiar with WordPress
this might not make sense at first but
then hopefully once we get into it it'll
make a little bit more sense but on the
the posts we made all these custom post
types right and we have these posts well
I've added in some custom fields right
by default WordPress has certain fields
like a title and content things like
that well I needed more than that all
right you'll see why when we look at a
specific case but I can't access that
data through graph QL so we're using
that WP graph QL plug-in and it doesn't
give us data from those custom fields by
default so to complicate it a little bit
more I've used a plugin called advanced
custom fields Pro to get that data or
I'm sorry to make those fields so what I
need to do is figure out a way in PHP so
most likely and we either add to the PHP
plugin that we've been using to make all
the custom post types or we'll have have
a new one I'm really decided yet we need
to figure out some way to
make those the data from those fields
available in graph QL through that WP
graph QL plugin
so I have some ideas so I went to the
git repository and there are some other
people who are trying to do the same
thing so I have some ideas based on what
they posted of their solutions and
hopefully from their solutions we'll be
able to piece something together that'll
work for our use case that's the plan if
anybody has any skills with WordPress
PHP you know WordPress plugins then
you're most welcome here and you know
feel free to chime in at any point all
right so I just got a message from one
of my student workers and he does not
have the level of access necessary to do
what I just asked him to do in WordPress
so let me give him access real quick and
then we'll get started
if you notice my head like kind of
blowing I'm listening to like nineties
rap music right now on Spotify so I just
finished the second season of Luke Cage
on Netflix and so now I'm of course like
remembering all this old-school rap
music because it's all the the
soundtrack for that show is all that
kind of stuff so apology so that anybody
else a fan of Luke Cage or the any of
the Marvel series on Netflix I'm a big
fan Luke Cage is one of my favorites I
probably say Luke Cage and daredevil or
my favorites out of all the Marvel
series okay alright so I gave him access
so I just made the student work in admin
hopefully hopefully he this then mess
anything up he seems to catch on pretty
quickly about everything so I think
it'll be good
so I just message them and said with
great power comes great responsibility
so see if anybody gets that reference
let me know where it's from
alright cool we're up to a decent
viewercount now so I think now is a
great time for me to get my face off the
screen and switch okay alright cool so
let me check let me show you what's
what's going on here so this is what is
this dress graphical I think that's how
you pronounce it graphical it's a Chrome
browser plug-in that lets us search
through our graph QL data so I've just
searched for menus so this is the custom
post type that I made and that I'm using
these custom fields with and you can see
here's what's available these are all
the fields that are available for me to
get data from there's a lot of stuff
there actually I'm probably blocking
some of it it doesn't matter because the
stuff we want is not it's not there
right and if you have this this
extension you can check out what we have
in graph QL as well if you'd like but
yeah I can't get access to that so we
need to change that let me show you we
log in here and I'm gonna show you what
this post looks like
menu there we go
menus let's see maybe this one alright
cool so we have this would be a
navigation menu that would kind of show
up on the right-hand side and just
scroll with the user and this navigation
menu would include these links and it
would appear on all pages that have to
do with Franciscan press or Franciscan
University Press I think we should just
call it Franciscan press though because
otherwise it gets shortened to fu press
and that's not really a good a good name
right let me get Christopher is asking
you for the link I'll put that in the in
the description yeah that's about fold I
should have just put it in anyway
alright the link to the graph QL
endpoint that I'm working with is now in
the live chat so you can check that out
if you want and I'm gonna throw in the
link to the dead version of the website
of the Franciscan University so you can
check that out as well that should not
take that long I thought I set it up to
always keep at least one instance
running I have to work on that if
anybody uses now from site and you know
why this could be taking so long let me
know because I'm not it shouldn't take
that one okay so let's just go to a
place that should have this menu so
let's let's check out Franciscan the
fresh sea maybe Franciscan magazine
should have I don't even have that route
setup yet okay
I still have to set that one up some of
the stuff down lower on the menu I guess
didn't get set up
households oh there we go
that's kind of odd why isn't that
working
all right cool well good to see that
that's not work to do anyway this
households page I know should have a
menu so we're gonna the menu would just
be on this side right where I'm not kind
of moving my mouse and it would just
scroll down with the user so I just
wanted to let you know where this menu
would be and then on mobile I think the
menu would drop to the bottom so I'll
actually make two different menus and
we'll just switch out visibility based
on screen width and we can do that just
with some two media queries with CSS all
right and I forgot to set my Pomodoro
time and let me set that now so I'm
gonna code for 25 minutes and after that
I'm gonna go to the live chat and answer
your question so I see some some
activity there in the chat so if if
you've asked something I'm not ignoring
you I'm just gonna wait until after this
25 minute period is up all right so we
probably won't even need to look at this
page anymore were mainly going to be
dealing with this page and with our our
PHP so let's scroll over there we go so
here's our our current plugin the
fastest way to get started I think would
just be to use this same plugin that
we've been using for all our custom post
types this plug-in is available on
github if you check out that FUS mark on
repository that's the same place we have
the repository for for this the
three-act project you'll see this
Francis and Franciscan custom post types
plug-in so you can check that out if you
like it's open-source feel free to
change it edit it use it for whatever
you need to but I think we could we
could probably just for now put some
stuff down here and then probably put it
in its own plug-in at some point cuz
this plug-in is getting really
really huge right
sorry about that my chute workers at
keeps asking me things on slacks
I want to respond alright so next thing
I'm gonna do is pull over this these
against examples that are here in this
repo and I'm gonna paste this in the
description so these are attempts that
other people have made to get this to
work basically to solve the same problem
that we're having and it seems like at
least some of them were successful okay
so this one was successful in particular
for the repeater field which is the
field that we're using so um I
definitely want to try this one first
there's a bit there's one that's that's
shorter it doesn't quite require as many
lines of code that we might be able to
utilize later on when we have some more
custom fields that aren't as complex as
this but for now I really want to try to
get this repeater field working because
I know if I can get this working I can
probably get anything working this is
seems to be the most complex example
that we could use all right so first
things first let's just copy and paste
this and start editing it and see if we
can get a different response here and
with PHP and WordPress plugins in
particular you know pretty much right
away if it doesn't work because usually
everything crashes so that'll be it'll
be obvious if we mess it up and then
also if we don't see the right data here
then we'll know right away
okay
all right that always seems like I'm
looking away from the camera but my my
other monitor is is over here so I was
gonna move the webcam to show you but I
I don't want to move it and then I give
everybody motion sickness so I'm gonna
hold off on that but my other monitors
here that's how I keep looking away all
right so I'm gonna read through this
anybody that's better at PHP than I am
which wouldn't be that hard to be better
than me at PHP please correct me if I'm
reading this wrong but I'm just going to
try to think through this so I can get
some idea of what's going on Before we
jump in and start changing things okay
so we're adding an action and graphical
exhibit fields in it a lot of these
functions are built into WordPress so we
we can just kind of have to assume like
this is gonna work this function does
something if we really are confused we
can look it up and probably we'll be
able to find it in the WordPress
documentation all right so we're gonna
add an action directives and feels
function feeds okay
okay so it looks like in this case
session
okay so session is the name of a field
alright good so let's let's change
session right now a little session safe
all right yeah let's change every
instance of session to link since that's
what we're dealing with in this
particular case so we just get get that
change right away
what it have
for some reason it's putting two S's
there but all right links Thanks and
then I need to capitalize it here and I
can't remember that was supposed to be
capitalized or not let's let's cap okay
Oh John you caught that about too many
S's there thank you alright so now let's
let's continue so we're creating this
new object type we've given it a name of
link a description one link row and then
your text domain I I mean this seems
like an example example text said but
I'm not sure what's supposed to go in
there so I'm gonna leave it like that
for now and hopefully we'll be able to
see this displayed somewhere later on
and then we'll get an idea of what it
should be alright so then we have fields
so in this case the fields that are
being defined for each row so I I'm
making a lot of assumptions here but I'm
assuming that each one of these is going
to be one row of our of our repeaters so
each row and our repeater feels is made
up of two fields and in this case they
have the UID and the name but in our
case it's going to be linked well let's
say link URL and let's call this
link name I'm pretty sure that's what I
named them and in both cases these are
strings so we don't have to change that
we're solve a custom post type and make
sure this is exposed to graph QL white
map space let me check that example here
where did it go
I don't know what that white map space
is okay in this app I'm I'm reading
right here the context of this there we
go white map space sessions have some
string fields and a field for a map
space the white map space custom post
type okay
in this Afghan of exhibits okay so the
main custom post type is a white exhibit
custom post type which can have a list
of sessions that's a repeater field so
in our case white exhibit is men you
know I'm not sure how some feels
sessions have some string fields and a
field for a map space white master days
custom Thursday so I don't know that we
need that white white map space all
right I think this would be a field
maybe that is connecting us to another
post type which we don't really need
right now on that one but it's good to
know that we can do that so let's get
rid of map space okay
all right so we've gotten rid of that
just good it's always nice to get rid of
code especially when you don't really
understand it anyway
one less thing to worry about all right
define the field containing your
repeater
link's returned a list because repeaters
are less okay type description
yeah
all right
all right this is graph QL exhibit
fields this is this needs to change
right unless this is just this name
could be whatever we want I guess it
doesn't matter but let's let's say menu
menus fields
let's say that the thing that I'm I'm I
don't get is these value should in some
way be connected to that menus custom
post site and I'm not seeing where that
connection is so let me check this again
I'm gonna scroll up and see because
there's a similar solution and I set
each unit I project that was sweet
it filled
using easiest get fuel so they get first
matter did we use good field
okay and you see some previous examples
with the same problem which the these
were of I believe failed attempts
oh it looks like there's a gist here
with another solution
we'll take one look at this whoa
okay so this section looks very similar
but this section is definitely different
interesting
and see
it says to use this get filled but I
didn't see it in here so let's search
for it there we go there it is get
filled links those okay you know what
I'm just gonna try this so I can't
really see exactly how this is gonna all
link up but I'm gonna try it
maybe I'm just missing something in it
it will work I hope that's the case all
right so I just copied that and I'm
gonna paste it
oops too many things open all right so
we're gonna go down to plugins this is
the WordPress admin panel in case you're
not familiar with that so I'm gonna go
down to plugins if I can find it there
we go and then editor you can actually
edit the code for plugins right here it
is not recommended obviously right I
would be way more hesitant to do this to
a site that was live but we're still in
development mode so the site has not
lost yet and I'm okay with this you
could definitely crash a live site when
doing this and ass update and hopefully
we don't get a white screen a great
refresh just to verify yeah no no weird
right white screen that's awesome now
let's go back here and just gonna run
that and see I'm gonna click on menu
again and see if we can
all right I'm not gonna dare but it
potentially it might show up elsewhere
so what did we call that link let's see
if we can find it you
see
I don't think that worked but we could
try reloading everything
I'm the chiclet um all right so if you
have some questions in the chat just
hang in there for about 6 more minutes
and then I'll answer some questions
is off medical order Shalini
I'm just gonna stroll down nope nothing
that's link yeah about that
I mean I'm gonna vet I don't think link
is the link we're looking for I'm gonna
verify that now yeah that's definitely
not the particular link that we are
looking for that's the permalink
all right so I'm not seeing anything new
in our our schema so first time didn't
work not really surprised at that
so let's see
let's see about this description for
Graffiato okay so all of this the
description one link bro
find the field continue
you know what we I'm wondering if this
is case-sensitive and that makes a
difference right because we are I don't
know if this would make a difference
here then usually when we're talking
about the description the name could be
what anything
you know what I should double-check and
see if I've what this slug before the
repeater is that I actually used all
right so let's go in here here's our
plug in our custom fields plugin so
we're gonna go check out every time you
make a new field in this plugin its
given a name but then it's also given a
slug
so the slug is the more useful thing
when we're dealing with the code so
let's check out links and this field
name is links let's make sure that's how
we did it yep so we did say links in
that link so I think this is fine
because are we talking about one link
yeah but here we have links
all right so that looks okay
all of us says set graph QL exhibit
fields and not graph QL menu fields okay
Oliver yes so it was exhibit fields
before but I thought exhibit I'll try it
out I'll try that out it just seemed
like before that exhibit was specific to
the project like exhibit was that custom
post type so I will try that out this
would be the last thing I try before I
answer some questions so go back here to
this and I just paste it in the new
stuff okay and now I'm gonna do a
refresh just to make sure nothing saved
there
it's
okay all right couldn't get it to work
yet let's take a five-minute break
answer some questions hopefully we can
think of some other things to try for
this I will say I assume that this
problem was going to take me a while to
figure out so like not something that I
would get done during today's stream so
as long as I'm making some progress
which I think we've made some progress
so far at least in figuring out what a
little bit about what doesn't work so I
think we'd be good progress is good okay
it looks like something you said
spider-man I was talking about Marvel
characters and I earlier that I just
finished watching season 2 of Luke Cage
and I really liked it
uh-huh looks like some of your
spider-man fans I always liked
spider-man when I was younger that was
my favorite spider-man and Wolverine
were my favorite when I was younger I
still like him
alright it looks like a lot of the stuff
in the chat or a discussion between some
of the people in the chat so I'm
skipping through some of it if I happen
to miss your question because I got lost
in the discussion just ask me again down
down below
okay Christopher thanks that graph cute
graphical extension that I'm using on
Chrome is called chrome chrome eql CHR
om e I QL so that supposed to be chroma
Cole I don't know what it is how you
pronounce it but Christopher said Oh PHP
is grass well I guess everybody has
their own preferences for first language
I will say this it seems like PHP does
get hated on quite a bit these days
chris is no js' all the way oh I mean I
much prefer node but sometimes you gotta
do what you got to do so I've never been
a fan of WordPress either I prefer to
implement the thing I'm trying to build
either with the library or by writing my
own version usually works better because
I know how it works yeah for sure
in this case I was not about to write a
whole content management system on my
own though I just didn't have the time
or the resources to do it and I mean
WordPress is extremely stable and has a
huge user base so there's no way I can't
replicate that
Kludd scences apollo and graph graphic
love react native I'm also a huge fan of
react native I have a react native
project going on on the side with
balance I oh so that that project is
coming along really well I can't wait
till we're done and I can actually tell
you all like a check it out in the App
Store if any of you are at all
interested in cryptocurrency I think
that that's going to be a really cool
app once we're finished with it our
automated sound kinetics says hi I'm new
to this channel I'm 18 and I'm really
interested in coding but I'm really
confused about choosing a programming
language to start with can anyone help
me out yeah it definitely depends on
what you want to do but if you have no
idea what you want to do I recommend
starting with JavaScript as your first
programming language and here's here's
why JavaScript knowing JavaScript will
allow you to make the largest variety of
things with JavaScript you can of course
do websites web apps but you can also do
native apps for both mobile and desktop
using electron and react native you can
even use JavaScript to do some machine
learning with like tensorflow j/s or
brain j/s you can do AR vr x or whatever
they are calling you know all the the
augmented reality and different types of
reality there ways to do with JavaScript
you can do Internet of Things stuff with
JavaScript I think it's is the
JavaScript library like johnny-five that
lets you do like Internet of Things
stuff I forget exactly what it's called
but there there's really to my knowledge
no area of programming that you are
totally locked out of in JavaScript but
with other programming language
you are a bit more limited right so not
that it would be impossible to program a
lot of other things in another language
but it's definitely not as easy write a
JavaScript just runs in the browser so
the barrier to entry there is it's just
so low now if you know you want to go
into a specific field but if you really
wanted to do machine learning or data
science I'd say go with Python if you
really really wanted to focus on mobile
apps for either iOS or Android then
maybe you want to specialize right so if
there's a certain company you really
want to work for and they specialize in
one thing go with that although if you
want to do anything that has to do with
the internet with with websites you're
gonna have to know some JavaScript at
some point unless you are completely
back-end and work in in some language
some other language right but if you're
all going to touch the front end of any
web app you're gonna need to know some
JavaScript so I say that's a good place
to go in terms of giving you the best
opportunity to explore and figure out
what you like if you want to know what's
like really easy to pick up honestly I
think Python is really easy because
there's not a whole lot of weird syntax
stuff going on with with different
characters it's all based on indentation
so Python seems to be easy to pick up I
have my eight-year-old is learning
Python right now so I think it's way
easier for him to use that because it's
indentation based instead of trying to
look for the weird characters and
knowing when to press shift on the
keyboard and everything so that's that's
my opinion on that so I I don't pretend
to be an expert but based on my
experience and my knowledge of the field
right now that's what I would go with
okay all right so I didn't get through
all of the chat but I'm gonna restart
this Pomodoro timer and then hopefully
get through the rest of the chat when
we're done all right
see
[Music]
all right so we left off with
we left off with a failure right we can
need it to work and the last thing we
tried was switching back to exhibit
instead of menus now the thing that the
thing that I thought was odd was that we
made no reference to the post type where
these fields were being stored or the or
that these were attached to write so
that menus post site is where where
we're entering the data so I'm wondering
if let's go back to our examples here
I'm wondering if in this example here
where basically this part matches up
with this
I'm wondering if all of this has to go
with it as well
let's see where I'm gonna copy and paste
this just so I can use my editor
shortcuts to to look through it and get
some syntax highlighting on it but maybe
we'll find our answer down huge let's
give it a lot of space so we know what's
what there we go now it's so much easier
just to read this with the syntax
highlighting alright so this is this
repeater field
so we're putting in a lot more info
about the repeater field objects I'd say
okay and then when we get down here we
see we have a different name here so
this isn't the stats fields graph QL
stats fields
okay so we're naming this I I kind of
think that this could change and it
doesn't doesn't necessarily matter to a
names description all right so this this
section like I eventually figured out is
supposed to be like this singular okay
so what we've done we've done in this
section I think will work field stats
what is that compared to
okay
all right so let's grab this right and I
should I'm gonna see where they just
goes we have a survey here do we
reference array anywhere down here
to be reference that particular array
and thinks
okay let's grab this and we'll add it up
here
modify it for what we need so instead of
stats we're gonna say links
I see links repeater field here's this
thing this key of field and then this I
wonder I wonder if we'll need that in
where we can get that from like if that
value is a sign when we've created that
I have a fan running in the background
on low let me know if that noise is if
you can hear that noise and if it's
annoying I'll try to turn that off if
it's if it's getting too annoying for
you all I'm gonna double check my
messages here
make sure there's no work messages so
many notifications alright I think I'm
good
okay that's that's the only thing that
I'm worried about here is that key like
where are we getting that key from and
then the subfields we definitely need to
change
see
I'm wondering
I'm gonna leave it as is what I'm
wondering is would with this code
actually register new custom fields but
it's nice not applying them anyway
all right let me get rid of this stuff
down here that I definitely don't want
this in here
and I'm gonna take one more look at this
something at the bottom that I was
interested in here
okay
all right so let's let's just throw this
in here right now and see what happens
I'm well I'm kind of surprised we didn't
get an error already but we'll see maybe
we'll get one here hey Nikki's here hey
how's it going yeah there we go
the PHP code changes roll back cuz in
Airlines 1703 an unexpected that's
interesting right because we we got that
you know we copied and pasted that right
from here so okay
well let's take that out I kind of think
we'll get another error but yeah
unexpected use alright so that code is
not gonna work
well let's take some of this out then
this
let's update just get rid of those
errors all right great
I don't wanna step back here
let's go there's our menus I'm gonna go
into the menus just to make sure you
haven't messed anything up so be a good
a good check to make sure that they're
there right all right that's definitely
not the right URL some of the old site
has some weird stuff like this so in
this case I'm not gonna attempt to keep
this URL okay well looks like it hasn't
messed it up
Nietzsche
all right can anybody hear me and see me
at this point I think it's worth you now
so yes so there's a huge thunderstorm
right now and the power went out so I
think I'm in it and the stream I'm
really sorry to end it so abruptly but I
think I'm gonna end the stream because
the odds of the power going back out are
pretty good so I don't I don't want to
keep having you know this this video
once it's you know available again have
these huge gaps in it so yeah so I'm
just gonna end this now try to keep
working on it I'm maybe I'll switch to
my laptop so that I don't have to deal
with the power one out but anyway thank
you all for watching and for your help
and advice during this I'm still gonna
keep working on this so this is an
important thing like this this really
needs to get finished before we can
launch probably other than that I'm
gonna add some more custom post types
and custom fields and have my you know
my student workers fill that that data
in and that'll basically be what I'm up
to Thursday I'll try to get a stream in
tomorrow it'll probably be from home so
I will try that if not I'll be back next
week and as always i'm available on all
different social media things you can
ask me questions and yes so until next
time have a wonderful day